this week's videos are sponsored by manscaped
and Shopify more on them after the reaction
people what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation it's time for Monarch episode 4
today John how are Ru AR can't wait man that
works yeah that works for me leave a like on
this video ladies and gentlemen also be sure
to subscribe and click the notification Bell
get notified when I reaction for episode 5 is
up here on the channel big thank you to prepper
for helping us edit down these highlights and
as always full anthr action watch along where
you sync up with your own copy of Monarch
available for our super sexy rejects over at
our patreon page over there we cover several
things exclusively with highlights and watch
alongs included thank you to all who have joined
our patreon page for the month of November hope
to see you over here in December let's get
in action and see what this episode's all
about oh o Utah Mormon
monarch
it's giving Hills Have Eyes and Breaking
Bad fine where's the atomic
bomb Jesse Jesse we have to
[Music] radiate old hunka junk is this what
the hell it's not even plugged in what was
it satellite phone it's Barnes I'm I'm
getting a really weird reading out here
and Barnes Outpost 47 yeah I need to
speak to assistant director ver Duo
that's a cool attention to detail it's
like her position doesn't even matter
isn't it Outpost 37 in the thing or 38
I don't know oh yeah right where we left
off
buddy get down get down man get
down Run come on get the rock oh
boy you did it look over
there all that is hurt for a 2C
distraction and they literally
just left my man right there oh
it's his fault man after a certain
point the thing you could have got killed you
idiot it is the year of retro
sunglasses that's a beautiful shot wow in the
hollow ice [Music] no yeah
that hurts that amount of
cold that dude looks really concerned for her
that's his love right there I think we're in
the clear for the moment oh God damn it son
of a b whoa my legs are soaking my got to
move quick you good am I good I'm going
to die of hypothermia are you happy we
came Jesus always fighting yeah he was
like no wonder my dad had two families
yeah
[Music] whoa this is an interesting
change
fair you're brand
man they don't buy into your product they buy into
[Music]
you like his father and multiple identities and
relationships his art is genetically passed down
yeah Mom shut up yeah stop supporting me
Mom that's why I went to Alaska show him
his art yes I brought these big faces with
me so Monarch is a commentary on parasocial
relationships yep we all think we know Godzilla
no so they started off bickering yeah it's
their core relationship trait sounds pretentious
incredibly you speak English hey you know what
would be incredibly respectful is if you yeah
delete the pick is there a reason you don't
like your picture being taken cuz she doesn't
know who you are it's a very nice picture
it's am I recently deleted are you hitting
on me just being honest do people say that in
real life I've seen it movies and shows all the
time are you flirting with me are you hitting
on me people are always asking me that do you
like whiskey I like expensive whiskey you're
in luck Japan has some very expensive whiskey
how expensive we talking we can't sit still with
that Titan on the prow you still think it's out
there hell if I know you still think it's out
there you're out in the middle of open snow or
it's around here somewhere the temperature's
going to drop by the minute we got no food no
shelter no doole where the hell are we going
we're lost Andy's gone and it's all your fault
oh God I think I saw something from the plane
some kind of structure looked like a big golf
ball it had to be man-made like a building or
settle oh a geodesic dome this episode better
win me over to their Dynamics you're not in
love with them I mean they are Charming in this
flashback pretentious this place is
a dum the that's the password is my
favorite Trope we chose this password cuz
we know it's a dump oh my Speak Easy okay
you proved me wrong the center framing on
this show with the Beautiful hair too damn
oh okay so you're a successful artist
I designed the lighting what no way is
that going to help them with fighting the
Hidan yeah they're going to shine a bunch
of lights on him is that why he just shot the
flare yeah he's like I could use this I know
this I mean I didn't say it was a bad act
I mean as far as acts go this isn't an act
oh he opens his body language I judge an
artist based on their art not on a suit
and a haircut oh the art why isn't the AR
first but influencers yeah come on you are
the the brand the brand why isn't this stuff
in the gallery these aren't for sale I mean
you could change that and change your life
people don't give other people a shot unless
there's something in it for them that's pretty
cynical well I mean but accurate when it money
anything such as selfless is that is there
a real quality you should probably go them
the rich Pricks are waiting you got to be
there in time for your dad not to show up
miss your dance recital not really my crowd mine
NE you get used to it hot shot no they wanted to
kiss get back to them fighting that was sweet
yeah this is too sweet for two too
long man can't relate to these guys
[Music] anymore we must go through the mines of
morio they called it a mine I know what I saw
I don't know what over there what where right
there what is that very noticeable blue light
maybe you're a local settlement the point is
it's out there right let's zip line across this
Canyon you don't know how far that is that
Titan can catch you before you get halfway
there you don't have noticed this whole time
none of them have had cold breath that is an
excellent call oh interesting I'm going alone
if I have to cuz I'm not a kid you think you
saw something yeah I know what I saw then go
and don't stop until you find it and then get
help we'll do the same in a different direction
the next time we see canaro who'll be riding a
Godzilla yes he'll be surfing on its back I
have tamed him radiation specifically gamma
raay in the 30 exz range where's is radiation
coming from that's a crazy thing you only see
these kinds of spikes from Pulsar super massive
black holes super massive black hole the last
time anyone saw readings like this was right
before the last emergence event from jira and
ukap flat before G jira jira is there no one
on set to tell her how to pronounce Gojira we
got to get every pronunciation possible
so that every culture's version feels
represented that's how we Pander most broadly
is that you yes it is oh cool shot good long
lens oh no ice where this has to be a Sound
Stage because yeah there's like things about
them physically that are distracting me of how
they don't look he doesn't look like he's actually
cold I'm just so surprised they wouldn't let me
car that back there's some cold breath there we
go just the body like just your nose and
your ears would be like in so much pain
red and yeah like leaky nose running call a
niit pick but I want realism in my Kaiju show
yes and the door opens up beneath him some
say freezing to death is a soothing way to go
[__] we're back at Dad's tent we are
going in Cycles this place it's Stranger
Than You Think it's Stranger than anybody
knows mystery box if we don't warm her up
she's going to die take your clothes off she
needs body heat she has everyone huddle for
warmth oh Beau we have entered hallucination
terrain go toward the light he's hallucinating
about this woman he saw 10 minutes ago it is a
oh it's a fly flat tell me why you don't want
to go to your gallery opening again why does
it matter do you Figo well it doesn't I don't
think you should be ashamed to take credit for
what you do what do you do yeah says you I just
brought you here and bured my heart is soul
you have been told me [__] about yourself
I do computer [__] computer [__] yeah
okay come on you mean to tell me the entire
natural phenomen on from aora boreales has been
condensed to your kitchen um you need to ignore
it who's lra I'm traveling for work yeah no
look you you got to stop calling me I'll call
you when I'm back yeah moved on so mysterious is
this still part of his hallucination yeah things
don't behave the same in a hallucination when you
get a phone call from lra oh it's we transitioned
into her hallucination they're sharing the same
flashback yes and they're both going crazy out
in the snow beautiful whoa I think their minds
are connected in some way yeah it must be the
juju from the Borealis stuff if anything happens
to me get in touch with my sister her name is lra
no let's not go there she's the only only person
that I can call let her go there I'm going to give
you her number I'm sure canara knows how no he
doesn't no [__] hope you're not talking about
me can have to Stu that fire this is nothing
but Kling I mean it's not going to last very
long and who knows what's in your dad's papers
theories discoveries where he went yeah I need
ideas yourself I got to say they got away from
that kaijou all things considered pretty easily
yeah you know you just hide in a cave for
a couple of minutes and then it's gone it's
just completely gone with no Trace hell of a
cliffhanger oh yeah let's see it oh let's do
this stop don't
move oh damn whoa what a dick Titan whoa
that's pretty cool I can't run from that thing
anymore no run run into it we can't dismiss
Bill randa's files Lee Shaw was there he knows
something that we don't that's why he's going
after the files quiet class I'm the troll from
the basement that you try to avoid in the break
room toally fine it's not like I work here for
the afterwork karaoke anyway oh my god get on
with it man we were here to learn everything
we can so no one else has to lose another loved
one in a Titan event bunch of people who signed
up to study giant atomic powered monsters be a
little bit more open-minded about it Tim that
Titan didn't go after us I went after the fire
didn't go after canaro went after that burning
airplane engine it was distracted by the
flare they wanted to eat that heat and why
did it toss that airplane like a chew toy and
come chasing after us because my brother tried
saving our asses by shooting a flare at it and
after the flare we were the warmest things maybe
it's cuz he thinks you're hot and this is how
we beat this damn thing we dangle the biggest
brightest hottest object we can in front of
it never been so thankful for a full bladder
aviation fuel better than Time Square on VJ Day
what what we build a bonfire VJ Day VJ Day what
what that going to scratch my head too long for
this what am I missing Is that real or a joke if
the time comes you ditch him too save yourself
Kate one of us has to make it out of here alive
a they're in love now you think kiry Clemens
is the daughter of Keith David from the thing
yes he got out hello what are you doing here
are you real my alone so did I that Papa papy
papy happy Rand is
it now that's cold cold
[Music]
soda what's down
there Nails teeth that's what it looks
like some type of shedding are you on
the back of a [Music] creature chains of shutter
speed Sinister
Tunes do like the disconcerting score element
ments yeah I got my [Music] wish whoa
oh is this real this is real [Music]
yeah what exactly is this uh yeah oh
interesting that's the sharpest
pencil blames his dad for
this of course
not a until now
for even the subtitles were fading
cool oh is it that radio thing that
that girl found must be or or
maybe they're linking somehow
yeah papa was here this is always sharpening
pencils very very very specific tick and then
I realized every time you took a shot
all you really whoa yeah oh it's like a
scream
run light it
[Music] up no
oh want the power from your
laptop dinner time you son of a
[__] whoa nice yeah well you too let's
go run and catch the [Music]
helicopter cool like strange
sound design for the creatures
noises that's not
good it's like Godzilla but with
ice money
shot wow oh you want to go down there all the
answers he's been looking for I never thought I'd
thank someone for abandoning their family but here
we are a they family just said it how you someone
had to fix the radio that I found left the mess of
shavings behind oh she knows the shavings too He's
Alive a I hate my sister damn it
damn it oh maybe the Kaiju could
eat the love power it's the strongest
force in the universe car sha it's an
honor to finally meet you [Music] yeah
wow oh boy wow wow wow wow wow wow wow
wow and now such Serene tones to guide us
out of the episode makes me want to do a
guided meditation for sure man out on the ice
breathing deep what's that in the distance pay
it no mind focus on the sound of my voice you if
you actually took it serious you would have been
able to meditate that's my problem always each
time just can't stop my internal monologue you
know you know with that laptop you could really
um build yourself a proper website that's true
you could and you could also use it to probably
get access to other websites to help you know
keep yourself a little bit clean yeah that's true
it's a little bit harder transition when you got
dual get some stuff the proper tools to yeah keep
yourself trimmed for any journey into whatever
Frozen T you hear that static over the radio thank
you to Shopify for sponsoring which is what we
use for our merch store and is our gamechanging
partner in eccommerce so whether you're launching
a passion project or scaling to new heights
Shopify is the e-commerce Powerhouse guiding
you at every step from creating your first online
store to opening physical locations Shopify makes
it seamless it's perfect whether you're selling
exclusive merch or unique Collectibles thanks
to their all-encompassing platform for both online
and in store sales their checkout system unmatched
it's 36% more effective at converting visitors
into buyers than other platforms and let's not
forget Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but seriously
reflecting on your journey using Shopify for
www.re naations shop.com it's been transformative
the transition smooth growth exponential thank
you again reject Nation from simplifying sales
to scaling our offerings Shopify has been a
Cornerstone of our success and Shopify isn't
just for us it Powers 10% of us e-commerce backing
businesses big and small in over 175 countries
their a war-winning support always there to guide
you so ready to join the revolution sign up for
Shopify at only a dollar a month at shopify.com
rejects all over overc case shopify.com reject
start your Shopify success story now let's
grow together with Shopify team Mary bsmi
reject Nation you know what the funny thing is I
already owned this product before agreeing to do
this partnership I could have used my influencer
ring to get it for free or at a discount but hey
now you can get it at a discount cuz this week we
are of course sponsored by manscaped as a married
man who's always on the move I value looking
sharp while keeping things efficient that's
where manscapes performance package 5.0 Ultra
comes in featuring the lawnmower 5.0 and it is
a game changer the package is honestly a perfect
gift for yourself or for another man that you
might know I'll give this to John if anyone ask I
pay for it out of my own pocket but no seriously
this is easily the best because it comes with not
one but two NextGen blade heads see the difference
it's good thing I have two now for demonstration
purposes so you got the standard trimmer for a
perfect neat trim but this one the new foil blade
for that super smooth finish and oh yeah it's all
about safe grouping with their Advanced Skin safe
technology plus they're waterproof so no more
crumbs on the carpet the package just close of
weed whacker 2.0 for ear and nose and I definitely
use this because look at me I'm a hairy guy and
the must have liquid formations the crop Soo their
aftershave lotion and the crop preserver ball
deodorant say goodbye to post shave irritation
and hello freshness and the ultimate cherry on top
two free gifts manscapes premium boxers 2.0 and
the shed 2.0 toiletry rag again I already have one
the boxers I'm wearing my pair right now and the
bag is perfect for all your grooming Essentials as
you can see so you ready to elevate your grooming
game head to manscape.com and use code rejects for
a cool 20% off plus free shipping remember it's
reject for 20% off at manscape.com let's get those
jingle balls holiday ready with manscaped thank
you guys for sponsoring this video we appreciate
the both of you all right John what did you think
about this hey I enjoyed this episode I like I
hate I don't think in one point in the entire
time we have filmed anything together I've ever
been like what' you think of this episode you've
ever been like I did not like that yeah I don't
think what I I I challenge anyone here to to find
one time where John's been like I don't like
this episode that's not to imply that I didn't
like this episode not in a well yeah it's harder
in this environment because too it's very fun
getting to do this and being able to watch it and
kind it's hard to be honest the camera point well
it's easier when it's just like you just walked
out of a movie and you don't have to my shirt
yeah my shirt John likes everything I that'll
be my specific real rejects official t-shirt at
reation shop.com and five people will buy it and
uh we'll know all of us will know uh yes uh uh
okay so instead of saying I enjoyed this episode
I will say that this episod I loved it I hated
it is it's you know it's continuing uh about the
same like level of quality I have come to expect
thus far for ouch for better mostly and for you
know could be a little better in other places but
I know but the way I read it ouch yes literal and
it's all immediate uh yeah so I hated everything
uh but I loved only the most trying to get clicks
are you yes absolutely woke Monarch just ruining
the legacy of monsters but no uh I like that this
episode was uh doing more of a character thing I
think that it was nice to have an episode that
decisively chose one character and went well two
characters really and went we're going to peer
in on them to kind of complement and flesh out
some of this stuff while we do the things in the
present like the things happening in the present
are like very very very straightforward at the
moment even though you do have the cool like
ooh space and time weird you know like oh when
you get too close to Kaiju things get strange
like they're still good at kind of stretching out
this mystery part but uh but it was nice to have
something with a little bit of tonal contrast
and contemplation to you know balance out the
rest of the stuff that's just like we got to evade
the monster and hey we got to go find these guys
got to give John credit man when even though he
likes everything he knows how to explain why he
likes it yeah I'll never just be like was good
goodbye there are people who will I know and I
should learn to become one of them I know so that
nobody ever knows what I think just uh you know
the basics I'll just give everything a number and
not say anything [Music] else yeah John are you
done are you done more uh I mean no I I that's my
nutshell review of the episode without like taking
everything that there is to I like this knife that
you've got here give something to talk about John
uh Hey top uh what do you think of Kento kentaro
this episode it's clearly the guy that you have
been uh you know champing for him you love Karo
and uh you know I've been sitting here going like
man you know I'm just waiting for that performance
to really kick in and uh you've been here in his
Corner being like he's my favorite actor in
2023 so what did you think did he rise to the
occasion uh I liked him more than I did in the
previous episodes I enjoyed his flashback scenes
I thought him and kiry Clemens had I think when
it comes to chemistry with actors people usually
chalk it up to they have great chemistry to
they have no chemistry and I don't think it's
either of those I think intermediate I think
they have middling chemistry is what they have
it is there it just could use more flavors it's
like you always feel like I these actors wanted
do the work and they're giving him some of that
I think um it is the Baseline generic flirting
chemistry yes and then the Baseline bickering
we're argumentative chemistry and we both have
these Hang-Ups that are you know grave to us but
maybe more easy to resolve than we I still don't
think the writing on them is part I think where
the show lacks in qualitative dialogue they make
up for a lot in aesthetic choices that evoke more
emotion often times that are stronger than the
characters better Direction than writing a th% I
think everything is better than the writing and
all I know people love the hell out of this show
and I like it I 600% on run to me I know I I like
it quite a bit and um I think the political stuff
is better written than just character scenes often
yes depending on the characters uh and so yeah
I I mean like the canaro and the what's her name
what's kiry clemens's character name May yes may
I think it's May yes I'm pretty sure it's correct
cuz like two minutes into wandering into the snow
he already it was like that Homer Simpson episode
when he was on his own and he's like he's got
like a beard is in Marge's car and just's like
it's been a day yeah yeah totally and it's like
you just watered off like 15 minutes ago I know
this show deals with like a span of time but man
I did not feel like they really earned getting
to like wandering lost in the snow uh and and
now hallucinating thing like and I think they
were trying to imply that there's that there's an
acceleration on the hallucination because of kaju
mumbo jumbo Hollow Earth things Crossing altitude
you know like there's there's a variety of things
I'm sure uh but I thought we got there like
really quick all of a sudden they do a decent
job of drawing mumbo jumbo that like sells the way
time passes enough in the immediate moment but yes
I thought that it had this weird time quality
in both sets of stories which is odd because
like I kept thinking in that in the flashback
like how long is this Gallery you've been at a
bar you went home you you made love you're in
bed you're getting out of bed like how long is
this thing and how long are people waiting
around for you and like how close is this
to the you're such a girl I just you know for
that ad that Advertiser friendliness you know
I don't want to say too muchy bang bang they
got Biz they had their they got it on they had
g g i don't know if I should say g day V day
yeah V Day G-spot day whoa John too too too
vulgar demonetized no a g spot is any where
Godzilla appears duh but anyway the way time
is compressed uh is a little funky and it's and
like I and you said during the reaction I too I
definitely said it I'm going to start saying that
you said stuff in the reaction that you definitely
did not say just see if people pick up on it
uh no I really enjoy and am fascinated by the
Aesthetics of people on like icy Expeditions and
the hardships that those involve and like I was
just watching a couple episodes of the show called
The Terror which is all about this doomed Arctic
Mission basically and it's like set in a much
earlier time but like that's a show that really
lets you live in the sort of like there are overt
monster horror elements involved but half the time
you are just like in the the real nastiness of
being out here and there were times where this
was flirting with that in ways that I liked but
at the same time at the end of the episode when
he shows up with a freaking helicopter I I was
a little bit like oh you know I yeah I I feel
like this is like very popc corny in the way that
it's conceived because it's like really clipping
along and it like has this sense of atmosphere
that pervades everything but it's like not paced
atmospherically in that sense or like it feels
like it needs to move in a way that I get like
I'm not I'm not upset about it and I'm like yeah
you know we need to kind of be Globe trotting and
going a bunch of different places but at the same
time for The Unique challenges that freezing to
death presents you know part of me is sort of
like you don't have to go full cannibalism but
on the other hand I am like I want to live in
the madness that is in that is setting in you
know yeah yeah I think there's I think there is
um I I kind of in all honesty I feel like the show
kind of pulls his punches a little bit I I think
I think that there is an a more interesting show
out there about Obsession and Desperation you
just saw zodiac yeah and I think there's like
a version there that these filmmakers kind of
want to tell but they can't it feels like they
can't it feels like yeah it's like they're being
restricted from going to all in on any one thing
yeah and I think I think they want to tell the
story about like uh people who have become so
obsessed with uncovering the truth of the Titans
and then watching what it's done to them as people
and how it's tarnished their relationships but
everything they do is with with that is kind
of just like the it's very boilerplate yeah like
the choices of what they choose to do with them
feels boilerplate and then once in a while you
get something that feels really rich like with
Cano's mom that felt like very rich uh but she's
the MVP we talked about the brother and sister
like a billion time so we're going to talk about
them but yeah I think they're uh they're kind of
bland and well and the show is all bit forgotten
the sister no they haven't I feel like no she's
rising to the occasion that's right she's best
friends with me now she's like we're not going to
let her die yeah they they went above and beyond
and and I do agree it's it's I'm sure it's there
in the in the text and it's in the immediacy of
the moment but this was also a time where I was
like you know may really is just kind of along
for the journey here to like add some cumber
some Stakes ESS I think kicking off with John
Goodman flashback at the start of the show is
kind of an indicator where I think they wanted to
go with this show uh like yeah you got the Monarch
people who are like government corrupt blah blah
blah but then you got like these other people who
have given up their whole lives for it and and
that is kind of what John Goodman's character
is like like you see what he was like as a young
young enthusiastic scientist uh explorer who then
became John Goodman you know we should all be so
lucky just this like grumpy guy who just hates
people like but I want the truth you know yeah
that's all I have now daily and ited enough other
people and I kind of think that's what they wanted
for everybody here is unpacking the truth and uh
you know Kurt Russell is charming as always The
Mont the Kaiju was cool cool Kaiju I like I like
the the visual telling of the Kaiju of how they're
like slowly trying to figure out what it attacks
and how to how to maneuver it I can't I have a
hard time getting on board with creature that
is um kind of made for the snow and then humans
can outrun it like [__] like that really easily
that really bothers me a lot I'm like you got
to know your rules little bit here not on some
weird [__] like Purgatory land yeah you know
yeah totally this isn't a metaphor moner this
is a real monster should be able to wreck all you
people yeah yeah like [__] like that was kind of
bothering like I feel like it totally would have
caught up with that helicopter yeah well and it
seems like it has started like going up it would
have just R yeah I feel like it would have enough
like push off its legs to Lunge at it or pull it
in with its suction or whatever you know yeah yeah
and like I liked a lot of that um and I do still
think they got away from it again it was just kind
of like very Baseline and I I I am curious why
people love this show I like the show so far with
occasional scenes that I love I kind of love the
third episode um I that's the closest I've come
to saying like oh I love that episode uh and I
think think again you know intent versus what
the actual end product is is very different and I
and for me I'm I'm curious to know why people are
so in love with it you know like does it go above
and beyond your typical Kaiju show or something
in the monster verse that does explore the humans
yeah it does I think it does go above and beyond
absolutely I think they put way more attention to
detail there than any of the monsterverse movies
have done uh at the same time does it earn like
great writing just because it's better you know
well or does or does more like like you know
what I mean like does does that does that mean
it is it is uh I I I don't want to sound like
I'm talking down to people who love it because
I want people to love what they love I just
I just don't quite get I'm not there yet uh I
don't see myself fully succumbing cuz I'm like
four episodes in we and I'm really not in love
with our main characters and and I I love like
Kurt Russell and the flashbacks when you're with
young white Russell and the scientists girl well
this episode also just in in sitting here now it
made me kind of realize like I I just realized
I said I don't like the people of color Yes uh
but I love my white man c yeah and his white son
W but I F I can't stand well the writers of the
cast need to how that sounded oh well this this
episode especially sitting discussing it now like
it I really did I think kind of share your your
enjoyment overall of the third episode and that
enthusiasm and the third episode in some ways is
the most meaningfully uh I thought this meandered
are we on five four this is four yeah so like the
last one was the most sort of we spent meaningful
like development time in the the 50s plot line and
this had none of the 50s plot line and I feel like
that is my favorite plot line easily so much
more intriguing and the characters in that one
while they're not like cuz that's when it's like
monarch Origins yeah which is really cool and you
get the fun Sheen of the period piece stuff the
aesthetic and and uh and and like the thing is
the three of them the trio of characters at the
center of that are the closest the show gets to
like actually having some interesting characters
where I'm not sitting here going oh this is like
and they are archetypical they are familiar but
but more less so than the present day where i'm
like this is like you know you open up the box of
like oh I got to get my wife back or like oh you
know we got all these kind of tropy character
things and yeah like when those plot threads
seem to all kind of be what the main uh present
day story is kind of riding off of and it's like
yeah you have them doing their romantic bickering
and stuff like that and then we see how they met
and yeah everything's very kind of familiar and
it's weird because Godzilla like especially the
American Godzilla movies are always kind of in
this weird pushpull of like how do we do people
and and how much do we do people and nobody wants
like a human too much of a human drama like it's
the 2014 movie but we don't want to also like
annoying and cartoonish the way like things can
kind of get in king of the monsters sometimes like
you know you don't want humans that are unpleasant
but you don't want to feel like that's the main
focus or something and like I feel like they're
splitting the difference by being as like kind
of generic about it to be agreeable as possible
or something I yeah I just think the melow drama
Rings flat yeah it just doesn't feel very alive or
very seasoned the whole thing with like I'm going
to go look for my dad I'm going to go off on my
own you made your own choice I'm like d and feel
like feel like emotionally voided at this moment
in time he's just like go that way and if you
succeed great and we'll go this way and if we
succeed great again it's like I I recognize intent
all the way I do and it's just when it comes down
to its final conclusion of what the final product
is it it does ring flat and then when you're not
cutting to the origins uh it it does ring a little
like the one that's most interesting to me is when
you're in the origins of the 50s or I find it
more interesting when they're just like cutting
to Monarch Tim man I feel like Tim is going to
rise as as an interesting character pretty soon
yeah I'm like I really know what the mystery
is that I'm supposed to be like intrigued by
and honestly like I iess JJ ABS that way there's
some there's something there I guess I'm supposed
to be but but I enjoy uh the pulse of whatever
is happening there I think yeah because I'm at
least like going I want to know what's happening
here when it tickles that part of your mind it's
like ooh conspiracy like this is the the more sort
of intriguing downto Earth Secret side versus the
you know High scale Secret side sure yeah yeah um
I think I do think uh yeah it's okay like if you
look at like Godzilla 2014 I think Aaron Taylor
Johnson who who was kind of crapped on for some
reason as being like a boring character yeah
just Dow and and and I don't agree with that
I I really don't I I kind of agreed with it the
first time I saw it but the second time I watched
it years later when I had like time away to where
I was able to just that hey Godzilla's not really
going to be in this it's my second time watching
it let me just watch this movie like that that
whole character makes so much sense to me as this
kid who like loved his mom and dad and then lost
the mom and he thought his dad went like crazy all
Sarah Conor on his ass then he's like I don't want
to be my dad I'm just going to like toughen up
I'm going to join the military come to find out
the dad was telling the truth so it makes sense
why he become this like like growing up in the
in military background why he would become this
insane main internalized serious person so like
the body language of his performance really
registered with me and I think everyone here
has like 20 times more dialogue than uh as like
individual characters has 20 times more dialogue
than Aaron Taylor Johnson and it's because Taylor
Johnson white is why I find no I'm saying that I
like I I think is such a much more compelling
character who I can get on board with than
everyone here who is given an exposition who who
has everything laid out and I I don't I I it does
B especially in episode like this where it's like
it's not really about the monsters and it's kind
of there like I don't really I just like I don't
really care and I think your placement sometimes
of when to do your like flashback episode is like
it's kind of a weird placement to to me to do it
yeah and especially to zoom in on taking your foot
off the pedal yeah and I mean like I like uh Ken
generally and I like seeing a window into his
character and M all that but it also seems like
okay we're on episode 4 we're changing the format
of the flashbacks and now we're doing this first
and it does feel a little bit like huh I wonder
why and I wonder why it wasn't maybe the girl that
we were set up to think is the lead who is now
like status 4 and all these scenes like uh sure
yeah I don't know yeah it does sort of I'm waiting
to see if maybe the rest of the season will draw
a clearer map for that and and two I mean I love
I just feel like I'm a such sometimes I feel like
I sound like a hypocrite because I'll sit there
I'll sit here with you and I'll go I want more
from them and they give us more and then I'm like
not doing anything for me well the thing is the
character I I get what you mean and it's no shade
to the actors it just feels I don't know there's
something that feels like there wasn't enough time
or like people were instructed not to go too deep
cuz like I like Kurt Russell I love Kurt Russell I
love watching Kurt Russell but here it pretty much
feels like you just plucked fun Kurt Russell and
we're like just have your personality be the heavy
lifting for you know these scenes in that you're
charming and we love you and I love how he's just
having fun he's just chilling and like and so it's
funny you know to me coming into this like again
big respect to Wyatt Russell I really like Wyatt
Russell but I wasn't expecting him to do like the
heavier lifting in terms of like I was like man
you know now he's in a position where he's like
acting in a way complimentary to his dad and
like that's going to be hard shoes to fill and
now in as of seeing what's happened thus far I'm
sitting here going why Russell is like doing so
much the heavy lifting in terms of like bringing
a character that I feel has like a a big level of
commitment but also like feels lived in even in
ways despite whatever dialogue or whatever like
there's something about that character and to a
degree the characters around him especially the
trio there and and when he's dealing with Chris
uh higher doll and and and all those people like
there's something that feels more alive about
those characters than the present day characters
and it's and something that feels like they
were just allowed to go deeper when doing the
homework or or you know kind of bringing the life
underneath the dialogue out whereas in the present
I can't tell what it is because again I feel like
each time it's it's never really the actors that
I'm upset about you know I feel like all these
people are capable but it's something about
the way that it moves and it and it and it does
like move I feel like pretty quick even though
it's good at selling you that it's not rushing in
the moment well I think the flashback the the the
Monarch origins in the ' 50s their characters
Naturally Fit for their immediate plot whereas
I kind of feel like they made up [__] to fill
in because they have notes for like well we got
to give our characters backstory we got to how do
we how do we make this more personal like you you
could I kind of get the sense more of the notes
that feel one feels very natural yeah uh because
their development is so intrinsically tied to
the advancement of Monarch yes whereas these
guys it's like this strange daddy issue show well
it feels like you should be heading toward like a
center point in some kind of complimentary way
where it's like yeah you have the past where
there for Learning and and charting this territory
and setting up the structure to study it and then
something kind of dark at the center of that that
the people on the current timeline are going to
discover that Kurt Russell maybe has to answer
in some way for that is going to be both maybe
a revelation that's I don't know to give it some
level of of heft or some level of conflict in that
like oh man maybe this went bad and it seems like
something in the past with Monarch is certainly
going to go bad but well I think what they are
missing and is it in the show and I'm just not
feeling it is what was my dad looking for well
that's the thing is it feels yeah the way it
if if they had that like as an as an element of
like you know it's it's another Trope but this
is like Trope show if if they had that Trope and
they zeroed in on that a little more like what
was my dad looking for what did he uncover about
Kaiju or the monster Titans what did he uncover
about them if they if they had a then it then it
kind of feels like you can have the development
and not take your foot off the pedal as opposed to
let's just slow down and show [__] of their best
story I feel like it is technically there but I
feel like what they focus mostly on is just dad
had two families and and he might still be alive
like that's kind of it and like and I liked his
presence when he showed up here but yeah like I
I feel like while it is technically there it's
not really something that they've done a lot to
accentuate or focus on yeah what was he searching
for what is the thing that drove him out into this
and how could maybe Kurt Russell's experience kind
of play off that and give us some insight into
that um because I think there's a way to do a
lot of archetypical and what when it's not working
you would call like boilerplate kinds of scenarios
or characters as long as you have and I think it
would be appropriate in a place like this to have
those archetypes as long as you've got a lot of
flavor going on in the performances and the little
details that make the characters Beyond just the
the broad strokes and I feel like it's taking it's
taking the you know very straightforward familiar
story mellow drama elements like really seriously
in a way that doesn't detract from like the
enjoyability of the show in the moment but that
does seem like it's missing a sense of fun well
it's starting to I guess like I'm still excited
it's weird like these are really fun reactions and
it's a really fun show to watch but then when you
start to break it down at least for for us it does
feel like I think like the only one I don't know
I really haven't listened to anyone's videos on
this yeah I haven't either I haven't listened to
anyone's videos but I see like how the how people
react on Twitter and I see uh the critic score and
I'm like I guess I'm just like in this weird camp
where it's like I think it's fine I I don't love
it though yeah well I think that's that's partly
the the treachery of Rotten Tomatoes is that like
all those could be sevens or six and a halfs
out of 10 quite glowing from what I've skimmed
it and it does create this weird dissonance where
it's good enough that I'm again happy to be here
and would love to see it grow Beyond this but it's
yeah it's it's a show where for the amount of like
Joy people have had over it and just remembering
recent times of you know the different receptions
of the monsterverse movies and the up and down
Journey that that has been it it does kind of
fascinate me that people are so glowing about this
because you know it's good good enough that I get
why it's popular anyway but yeah the fact that
everyone's like 100% I'm like this is the moving
Godzilla drama that that you haven't felt like uh
you've gotten in various movies or whatever else
like at least of the movies even though the the
human characters can be flat um you know it's just
building to the climax of the movie yeah I'm like
at least there's like exciting action to you know
distract your mind and and feed your like stimuli
yeah whereas this feels like it would just be
an ongoing melod drum it really does you know it
happens to that monsters sometimes and that like
maybe they'll find their dad at some point but
like and like the visuals of the of the of the
tight ends are are really cool yes because it's on
a television show and a lot of the times I'm I'm
like well if I saw this exact visual in a movie
theater would I be as impressed or would I just
be like I appr appreciate it yeah would I actually
logical stance I appreciate it would actually be w
i I think this but I think on TV you're like wow
for TV this is amazing you know I feel like this
for me like this could have been the ice episode
you know or like the Arctic whatever wherever
they Alaska this could have been the thing yeah
this could have been the thing episode or the
the something episode whereas like you know this
is a pretty good episode four to me but I feel
like the the the ever like all the trappings of
this could have been like I you think coming to
The psychosis of the past that that was just
like it it didn't seem like it had anything
really to do with the immediate plot it was just
like they're in the ice and they hallucina well
it seems like the only reason of mentioning the
the fact that all like time and space are sort
of weird and funky and different around Kaiju is
just to explain way that one Loop they do and to
kind of bolster the transitions when he's like
wandering around and then the radio brings him
out of the flashback and all of a sudden he's
inside like but generally it doesn't feel like
that sense of magic is like or that you know
strange sci-fi is like truly everywhere here I
can't just turn off my brain and have fun with it
I I can't cuz I'm so distracted by a potential and
B weakness you know I am distracted cuz the show
treats it like it's [__] Prestige television is
working hard enough on certain things to clearly
indicate that it wants to do that but it's also
not really paying much M to certain other things
that are essential to actually becoming that it's
so strange to watch so I mean honestly this might
have been my like least favorite episode of them
all in some way like for for impact again like the
promise of the setting and the kinds of movies you
could omage just the kinds of situations you could
homage in this place are like nice and Rich and so
in the moment I think you're you're always kind
of benefiting of the doubt because you're like
oh maybe some kind of real set piece is going to
give away but the fact that they outran that Kaiju
like twice with her legs freezing off that really
bothers me it really does I'm like this is kind
of [__] honestly you know a little bit like
they're not just combating like running in the
snow they've also got a mild snowfall they're
fighting against that FL apparently fluctuates
between storm to snowfall and and and I I just
like there's no way there's no way they would
have outran this [__] this is you're on this
Monster's Turf I'll give you the beginning I'll
give you the beginning but the very end moment
like what no yeah no and it undercuts the threat
it does it's it's it really annoys me and that
whole thing happens pretty fast like when he
showed up with the helicopter I was actually kind
of disconcerted at first I was like wait a wait a
minute who's flying right now you sure yeah how'd
you get here so quick you know but yeah uh uh yeah
it it's it's really fun in the moment and you keep
hoping that something else is around the corner
and I think that's what the mystery box element
does and that's why I'm worried about the JJ
Abrams of this because I think in some ways that's
a great tone like I think it's stuff like lost
I'm like that's the kind of tone you want for a
monarch show sort of creeping conspiratorial dread
uh but also I'm just aware that sometimes those
mystery boxes don't have anything in them you know
except for Vibes which are cool but uh yeah I like
kentaro's house his art show is fun interesting I
guess an interesting I don't know I it's it's it's
not a bad choice but at the same time it is one of
those I have so many other questions I shouldn't
be having because of stuff like that yeah I don't
uh I I don't this is my least favorite of them all
I still like the show it's done enough good things
for me to to like it um but I guess I just I'm not
over the moon about it uh and that's all that's
missing for me is uh being more enthusiastic
sort of missing yeah so intermittent um but
what do you guys think are you in love with it
are you mad at us oh don't bead you make it this
far I'm not reading the comments on this oh you
should all I like is that woke trash Doctor Who
that's right H the MEEP the meeps coming for you
g your woke ass pronouns yeah screw anybody who
uses a pronoun as if doctor who hasn't had very
over cheesy writing countless times never they
ruined Doctor Who I'm like there's way worse drct
who epod I have a feeling that this is in a well-
ingrained tradition across shows like doctor Star
Trek various other things terrible terrible Doctor
Who epodes that was that was one where I was like
uh the audience the the reception of a certain
crowd is going to be insanely predictable and I'm
also going to be here going you guys clearly don't
know Doctor Who because you guys clearly tuned in
just now there are some shittier episodes for sure
yeah some with thinner Veil attempts at uh you
know you know there's channels out there who are
like they about trans people and they acknowledged
the existence of and they were on the nose about
it h i need to pretend to be mad this is really
taking away from my ability to thrive as a human
being right now need to pretend to be mad so
that way could get my views this is about me
and it is distressing yeah I need this fixed
H it's okay it's okay you knew it was coming
as long as Godzilla doesn't get woke you know
somehow they manag to slip some Asian leads in a
black lead in here too it is cool to see um Asian
people in a in a I don't know if they're actually
Japanese um so it is cool to see Asian people um
as the leads of a show about in the god of univ
seems I mean but clearly uh only care to make
maybe one of them the lead at a time Caucasian
creators behind the show definitely really did a
better job writing Caucasian characters and they
don't even need to like lean on I appreciate the
effort though like hey he actually speaks Japanese
and there's like a cultural thing going on with
the girl and I would love if this was like really
B cultural that way they don't need to make it
about the culture but I appreciate the intent
to to anyway look I'm I'm done Don I'm over this
SP that needs to be spilled and we keep talking
and I got my doctor who rant out yes yeah like
I'm not diving into these comments I'm going to
embrace the fun sure because if you're upset about
Doctor Who you should probably go examine some
other things about your life yeah like if you're
really that mad about it oh I was like I'll give
you it's overt and on the nose and I'll be like
and they've done that with many topic other topics
yeah not that's do for you oh what a resolve
that needs to get a couple themes out is not
the name of Dr not one name one other time it's
okay ambiguous ending sometimes but no subtlety
I would not be like that's Doctor Who for you open
to subtle interpretation there I don't know what
this episode was trying to say allegorically the
reason the reason Doctor Who has episodes that
truly stand out like midnight like midnight like
blink oh um like the kapal episode where he's in
the time uh chest or whatever prison yeah the
prison yeah is because those are few and far
between yes yes yes there is a steady contrast and
uh and yeah Hest episodes Pooler some of the most
impactful there's a reason those episodes are huge
cuz they're not they're not as common true and you
got to and that's part of a of an EOS sense SC why
do you think they stand out why do you why do you
think they stand out because the rest of the time
there's a wide range of Tes super Exposition about
it yeah let's get mad cap and let's just throw a
bunch of [__] at you and let's wrap it up real
fast cuz we don't actually have enough time to do
all so let's just tell everybody what the point
is and get out of here Jesus guys Jesus [__]
acting like oh God so annoying yeah I don't know
at that point in some ways I'm like I go on the
nose because the people are going to get bent out
of shape about this if go you go subtler on the
nose you're going to get the same reaction yeah
or you'll get people champing something for the
wrong reasons I liked it because I could tell
this is not the greatest writing but they are
so gungho about it in the most overt way that
I'm like hey man you're embracing it and you're
doing it with a giant smile on your face this
seems almost intentional the way that you have
made this point blank straightforward because
I think you want to to upset and RI the people
who are going to be ignorant towards you're like
weed them out yeah yeah yeah and hey like let's I
mean big respect to a broad display of acceptance
because again in the community that that is for
I I can imagine being Overjoyed there are people
who who are completely for the message but don't
like the way it was written and I was kind of in
the middle there of like hey there are Parts
about this writing and I'm like I do not think
this was well that moment was well written um
but there but I'm talking specifically to the
camp that's like ruined by do who that's the
C woke that's what I'm talking about cuz I'm
like this show has been so [__] woke I don't
care what anyone says you know that's half the
point I'm sure the second [__] black Martha
Jones or lesbian Bill like come on Jesus doctor
one point has like a whole Cod of like lesbians
help out weren even around for that and I'm sure
that existed yeah yeah yeah um and then people
forget that that's half of what a lot of sci-fi
is for is just for giving us metaphors to help
people better swallow just basic tolerance anyway
but uh yeah leave us your thoughts on Monarch
episode 4 and you thought of the [Music] woke